chess Queens are a trained to attack on
site they see a piece of the other color
they capture it that's their job
there was a normal Queens I want to tell
you about peaceable Queens the question
is you have a chess board of a certain
size could be 8x8 or it could be 4x4 you
would like to put down as many Queens as
you can
some black Queens and some white Queens
but they must not attack each other two
constraints in this problem equal
numbers as many as possible and they do
not attack Queens of the opposite color
so this is a problem that Don Knuth told
me about in 2014 and I like the problem
a lot because it has some lovely
pictures it's an easily stated problem
and we don't know much about it and
there's a really incredible conjecture
suppose we have a four by four
chessboard and we want to put down black
Queens and white Queens so they don't
attack each other so if you put two
black Queens in the two corners and two
white Queens in the two middle squares
the black Queens do not attack the white
Queens and the white Queens don't attack
the black Queens immersed you can put
down as two there's no conflict when two
white Queens can see each other here the
white Queens want to avoid being seen by
the black Queens and vice versa this is
a lovely problem because it's really
really hard we know very few terms so
let me show you what we actually know
about this so for a two by two if you
put a black queen here it attacks the
other squares for one by one you can't
do anything so what we know is that for
a one by one the answer is zero for a
two by two the answer is zero what about
a three by three if we put a black queen
here it attacks all the squares except
these two so we could put a white queen
here we can put a white queen here too
but we'd have two white Queens and we
cannot put two black Queens so the
numbers have to be equal okay
all you can do is one one of each color
the Manx for its - - is the most we can
do so what about five there are actually
a lot of solutions to the 5x5
but there's one which is overwhelmingly
nice and you put four at the corners and
you put four in the other obvious places
there there there and there and you see
they cleverly avoid each other and you
can't do more so for five the answer is
four for six you can do five four seven
I think you can do seven on a regular
chess board you can do nine now in black
nine white and they don't attack each
other and you notice they come in clumps
and that seems to be a very good way to
do it if you go to a bigger board then
for nine we can do twelve ten fourteen
for an 11 by 11 board you can put 17
black Queens and 17 white Queens
12:21 and 13 24 and very recently just a
couple of weeks ago someone found the
next term which is 28 beyond this we
don't know you can use things like
simulated annealing to run to get lower
bounds to get things that look pretty
good and maybe optimal and you can use
integer programming to get upper bounds
to show that you can't get more than
such-and-such but the exact value is not
known beyond that point although we have
some conjectures so here is a very
plausible looking solution which has 58
black Queens and 58 white Queens on a
twenty by twenty board and this is a
construction which says if you
generalize this and put the Queen's into
fork five sided clumps a clump here a
clump here a clump here and a come here
then you can do very well as well as we
know in every case we've looked at
except one small case the answer is at
least seven N squared over 48 for an
n-by-n
ward so four clumps which have five
sided this picture here shows the
general situation now could this really
be optimal we don't know I think it's a
beautiful question so I run this
collection this database called the
online encyclopedia of integer sequences
and when we got to a quarter of a
million sequences it's not that much but
to us it seems like a lot all different
all interesting hopefully they're all
numbered so that we're the first one is
a 1 and a 2 normally they come in every
time a new sequence comes in it gets the
next free a number and we were around a
quarter of a million so we had a
competition to see which would get the
sequence number a a quarter of a million
a to five zero zero zero zero I have
collected the votes I did what is
traditional how I made my candidate win
and here it is lovely problem another
amazing conjecture could this really be
the right answer is this when God is
playing chess with the universe it is
this where he puts his peaceable Queens
it could be or it could not be it's a
toss-up right now hopefully we'll get
more data you know what I would do if I
add a team of assistants I'd pick say a
30 by 30 board and use some
hill-climbing method or hook jiva's
pattern-matching optimizer to find you
set it up as an optimization problem
it's an integer programming problem
maximize the total number subject to the
constraints then the constraints are for
each row and column and diagonal you
don't have black and white on the same
so I've been looking at brilliant
today's episode sponsor for some chess
related puzzles particularly ones about
the Queen and they were plenty actually
but here's one I liked what's the
biggest number of white Queens that can
be placed on a chess board in such a way
that a black King also placed on the
board is not under attack and you can
place the King wherever you think is
most profitable you got any idea
you're also asked to ponder this for a
chess board of any size now if you like
puzzles quizzes courses things like this
brilliant is the place to be their daily
challenges are especially popular and
always worth a look have a look at some
of these so whether it's just for fun or
to get serious about upping your
problem-solving skills giving yourself
bit of a brain upgrade check out
brilliant org slash numberphile the
address there's on the screen using the
numberphile suffix
that's gonna get you ten percent off one
of brilliance premium subscriptions that
unlocks everything on the site that's
brilliant org slash numberphile 28
another way of saying 28 is 28 but I'm
not sure that that's the right 28 maybe
you want a different 28 28